A travers les époques, les dangers
Une grande aventure les appelle
C'est, c'est, c'est l'Epopée Temporelle
Narrateur: Notre aventure touche à sa fin
Iris, LaBuse, Eliott, nos trois héros, ainsi que Thomas, ont enfin récupéré les 3 reliques
Et partent vers les coordonnées laissées par le Docteur Simon
Je suis trop pressé que vous entendiez la fin! Vous allez voir, c'est ouf!
*Bruitages de voyage dans le temps*
Iris: Ah!
Thomas: C'est... Calme
Eliott: Nous sommes dans la banlieue de... Melun, en... 1997
Température... 17°. Pluie... fine
LaBuse: Eh bah j'pensais que le futur f'rait plus rêver, moi...
Iris: Malheureusement, ce sont les années 90, l'époque la plus chiante de l'humanité...
Thomas: C'est peut-être ici en fait "l'infiniment moyen" d'Isaac Newton
Iris: Y'a rien! Tout ce chemin pour ça? Pourquoi mon père nous a amenés jusqu'ici?
LaBuse: Bon, faut qu'on s'active! Ca fait au moins 2 heures qu'on discute!
Eliott: Ca fait... 20 secondes
LaBuse: Oh bon sang, ce lieu est maudit...
Tous: Ouah!
Thomas: OUAOUH!
LaBuse: Qu'est-ce que c'est?
Thomas: C'est quoi ce truc?
LaBuse: C'est TOUT BLANC!
Iris: J'arrive à peine à ouvrir les yeux!
Eliott: Cette déchirure aveugante devant nous m'a tout l'air d'une faille spatio-temporelle
Thomas: Une faille quoi? Hé, y'a quelqu'un à l'intérieur, non? Là, regardez, en tout petit!
Iris: PAPA?! C'est mon père?! On a retrouvé mon père!
Thomas: Bonjour monsieur! Enchanté de vous rencontrer! Moi c'est Thomas, le p'tit cop...
Eliott: C'est bien le docteur Simon, au fond de la faille. Et il essaie de nous dire quelque chose!
Iris: Il nous entend pas! Euh... Allez, on y va! Sautez dedans!
LaBuse: Huhuhu, j'adore sauter dans les trucs que j'sais pas c'que c'est!
Wuhuhu! A l'abordage! Wouhou!
Eliott: C'est parti!
Thomas: Les gars, ça a pas l'air dangereux?
Iris: Allez!
Thomas: Tu fais quoi, Iris? Non, NON! Hé me POUSSE PAS!
Iris: GO!
Thomas: Aaah!
LaBuse: Beuh?
Thomas: Ouah!!!
LaBuse: Mais qu'est-ce que c'est?
Thomas: C'est vraiment tout blanc! Partout...
LaBuse: Où qu'on est?
Dr. Simon: Iris?
Iris: Papa!
Dr. Simon: Qu'est-ce que tu fais là? Et toi, KB-28?
Eliott: Je suis heureux de vous retrouver, Docteur Simon. Vous m'avez appelé à la rescousse, et j'ai apporté votre fille
Elle est comme une soeur pour moi, vu que vous êtes comme un père!
Dr. Simon: Et c'est qui, eux?
Thomas: Enchanté monsieur, j'me prés...
LaBuse: Buse, LA Buse. Je vous tue même pas, parce que mes Des Amis me l'ont d'mandé!
Dr. Simon: Mais pourquoi la faille s'est refermée?
Iris: C'est bon papa, on t'a retrouvé! Et on a récupéré les reliques, comme tu nous l'as demandé!
Dr. Simon: Quoi? Les balises retour? Vous avez ENLEVE les BALISES RETOUR?
Mais c'est pour CA que la faille s'est refermée! Pourquoi vous avez fait ça???
Iris: Mais, c'est toi qui les a placées pour qu'on les récupère! Ce sont des objets qui nous relient, papa!
Des cadeaux qu'on s'était faits pour prouver qu'on était une famille!
Dr. Simon: Mais pas du tout! J'ai pris des objets au pif à la maison, des trucs qui pouvaient ressembler
à des reliques pour que personne n'y touche jamais! J'y ai inséré des balises pour assurer mon retour
et vous avez tout foutu en l'air! On ne pourra plus jamais sortir d'ici!
LaBuse: Euuuuuuuuh... Quelqu'un comprend quelque chose?
Eliott: La situation est délicate. Précision... on est dans la merde
Dr. Simon: Pourquoi vous pensez que je les ai cachées à des endroits très précis et
que j'ai demandé aux gens sur place de les protéger?!
Sans elles la faille se referme!
Thomas: J'me disais bien qu'elles étaient bien gardées, ces balises à récupérer! A un moment, j'ai même failli
faire la remarque, mais comme y'avait des Conquistadors qui essayaient de nous tuer, ça m'est sorti de la tête
Eliott: Oh, je vois! C'était une triangulation multi-temporelle fixe pour maintenir la faille ouverte!
Dr. Simon: Exactement!
Eliott: Astucieux...
Dr. Simon: KB-28, tu ne pouvais pas le comprendre avant?
Eliott: Quand ça vous arrange, je suis une cafetière, mais tout d'un coup, je fais une erreur de jugement sur un
procédé qui relève de la mécanique quantique, et je vous déçois? Super...
LaBuse: Vais faire semblant d'avoir tout compris, moi!
Thomas: T'inquiète, j'fais ça tout l'temps
Iris:Attends, les reliques n'ont rien avoir avec moi? Mais j'pensais que... Mais pourquoi tu m'expliques
jamais rien?! Tu m'as jamais parlé! T'as jamais levé le nez d'tes machines depuis qu'j'suis née!
Dr. Simon: Mais pas du tout, au contraire! Iris, si j'ai fait toutes ces recherches pour trouver cette faille,
c'est parce que quand tu es née, je me suis rendu compte de la valeur que tu avais.
J'ai voulu maîtriser le temps pour pouvoir en passer plus souvent avec toi
LaBuse et Thomas: Oooooh!
Iris: Mais t'aurais pas pu tout simplement passer du temps avec moi dès le départ?
Eliott: La logique du Docteur Simon se tient, mais je préfère largement celle d'Iris...
Dr. Simon: De toute façon on a tout notre temps, maintenant, puisqu'on est bloqués
ensemble ici, dans cet espace vide pour l'éternité!
LaBuse: Mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait? Je sais, on fait comme quand les pirates découvrent une
nouvelle île, on repeuple cet endroit! HAHA!
Iris: NON, non! Je suis la seule femme! J'ai le choix entre un pirate, un robot, mon père et mon ex, alors on va rien repeupler du tout!
Thomas: Hum, euh... Docteur Simon, euh voilà, c'est pour vous dire que j'ai traversé toutes ces épreuves pour vous dire que votre fille...
*Bruit de re-temporalisation*
Aliénor: ...de gros dégueulasse!
LaBuse: Beh, la poufiasse?
Aliénor: Fichtre, pourquoi c'est tout blanc? Dame Iris, dites-moi comment on arrête cette machine diabolique!
*Coup de feu*
Hitler: AGH!
Tous: Hitler?
Dr. Simon: Hitler?
Thomas: Oh putain y'a Hitler dans une faille temporelle qui vient de tuer Aliénor la reine du Moyen-Âge!
Eliott: C'est précisément ce qui vient de se passer
Hitler: C'est fous, c'est fous qui m'afez poussé des centaines de fois par la fenêtre
Che me soufiens! Fous apparaissez sans cesse derrière moi jusqu'à ce que che sois expulsé de cette boucle
machiafélique et que ch'apparaisse ici piégé!
Oh che suis defenu fou, CHE SUIS DEFENU FOU!
Dr. Simon: Qu'est-ce que vous avez encore fait?!
Iris: Bah, disons qu'on s'est amusés à pousser Hitler d'une fenêtre une fois ou deux...
Eliott: 547 fois, jusqu'à ce qu'il disparaisse du temps, sinon ils auraient continué encore longtemps!
Thomas: Oh le fayot!
Hitler: Et ma fureur est 547 fois plus grande!
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAGH!
IIIIIIICH
BIIIIIIIN
SEHRRR
ENERVEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEE
Thomas: OH PUTAIN! HITLER EN SUPER GUERRIER!
LaBuse: Bon sang, sa moustache a changé de couleur! Elle est TOUTE JAUNE et EN BATAILLE!
Dr. Simon: Mais qu'est ce que vous AVEZ FOUTU! On est coincés dans une FAILLE TEMPORELLE avec un HITLER DEMONIAQUE!
Thomas: C'est vrai, dit comme ça, on a un peu foutu la merde...
Hitler: Ch'usqu'à maintenat, ch'ai été plutôt chentil, dans ma fie, mais là...
Che fais être MECHANT!!!!!
Iris: Quoi? Comment il peut être encore plus méchant?!
Hitler: Admirez ce qui fa sortir de ma BOUCHE!
AAAAAAAARGH!
*Bruit de tir*
Thomas: WOW!
*Bruit d'explosion*
Hitler: Boules de feu!
Thomas: Oh les boules de feu!
AAARGH!
Eliott: Attention...
*Bruit de tir et d'explosion*
Iris: Courez! Evitez les boules!
LaBuse: Enfin un adversaire à ma taille!
Hitler: AAAARGH!
Thomas: Aaah!
LaBuse: Je vais m'occuper de ses boules de feu avec ma célèbre hache!
*Bruit de tir*
Eliott: Ouh là!
Thomas: Ouah!
LaBuse: Haaaaa!
Hitler: NICHT! AAAAAH!
Hitler: GNAH! ARRETE DE RENFOYER MES BOULES! SALE PIRATE!
Thomas: Vous allez être surpris mais je me suis un peu fait pipi dessus...
Dr. Simon: J'imaginais pas du tout finir ma vie comme ça!
Iris: Merci papa! Enfin un point commun!
Eliott: Fin du calcul... Solution optimale disponible! Docteur, j'ai trouvé comment nous sortir de cette
mauvaise passe. Regardez mon plan!
Dr. Simon: Ah oui, j'avais oublié la machine de la reine. Si on prend 2 machines à voyager dans le temps et qu'on
fait ça... Mais oui! Bien joué, KB-28! T'es la meilleure machine à café!
Eliott: Merci, Docteur!
Iris: Mais attends Eliott... Pour réaliser ce plan, il faut te démonter entièrement et utiliser tes pièces?
Eliott: Exactement. Les machines et mes composants serviront à construire un vortex dans une fenêtre. Ca peut fonctionner.
Thomas: Quoi? Mais Eliott, tu vas mourir?
Eliott: Je vais cesser d'exister, mais, ce n'est pas grave. J'ai découvert l'amitié avec toi, Thomas. Iris,
je sais au fond de moi que je serai toujours ton frère même si tu ne veux pas être ma soeur et, Docteur,
chaque café que je vous ai fait a compté pour moi. Au niveau microscopique, j'ai toujours écrit "Papa,
je t'aime" avec les grains de sucre. C'était mon secret. Je crois que j'ai découvert l'humanité auprès de vous tous.
J'ai cru que c'était un bug, mais c'était de l'amour.
Thomas: Eliott, non...
Eliott: C'est la seule solution. Je m'éteins. On se revoit de l'autre côté.
*Extinction d'Eliott*
LaBuse: Attention les Des Amis!
Iris: Attention papa! Ah!
Thomas: Ouh là! Ouf!
Iris: LaBuse, continue de l'occuper!
LaBuse: J'commence à fatiguer... Ce moustachu est sacrément coriace malgré son déguisement!
Dr. Simon: Il y en a encore pour quelques minutes... Pour construire le vortex à partir d'Eliott...
Iris: Thomas, t'as vu le plan? Toi tu restes juste là sans bouger!
Thomas: Et bah parfait! Ca c'est une mission pour moi! Restez ici!
Hitler: Maintenant, che tire des LASERS afec mes YEUX!
Thomas: Mais c'est n'importe quoi, il chie sur mon enfance! Aucun Super Saiyan tire des lasers avec ses...
OUAH! Ta race! C'est chaud ce truc!
Iris: Pas bouger Thomas! Hitler, viens plutôt t'battre par ici!
Hitler: ARGH! Toi, tu fas goûter à mes lasers! Ils ont le goût de la mort!
LaBuse: Eh, mais c'est une réplique à moi ça!
Thomas: AH!
Iris: Attention!
Thomas: A terre! Oh putain le con!
Dr. Simon: C'est bon! Tout est en place. Le vortex devrait s'ouvrir
Iris: Ok, ça peut le faire. Thomas, tiens-toi prêt! Papa, ouvre la fenêtre!
Dr. Simon: Ca marche, c'est ouvert!
Iris: Hé, Hitler! On est là juste derrière cette fenêtre!
Hitler: ARGH! Mais che n'ai PLUS PEUR des fenêtres! Nous sommes coincés ici!
Iris: Maintenant Thomas, pousse-le!
LaBuse: Pousse-le!
Dr. Simon: Maintenant Thomas!
Thomas: Comme on dit dans ton pays, ADIOS HITLER! Yah!
Hitler: OUAAAH!
Dr. Simon: Voilà!
Thomas: Ouh, ok... Et maintenant?
Hitler: CH'EN AI MARRE DE TOMBER!
Iris: Regarde!
Dr. Simon: Les deux machines à voyager dans la fenêtre ont créé un vortex. Hitler tombe à l'infini
Thomas: Ah ouais, comme dans Portal...
Hitler: J'ai le SEUUUUUUUM!
LaBuse: On a trouvé quelqu'un de plus cruel que moi! J'adore ton père, Iris!
Thomas: Ok, c'est cruel, mais comment on sort d'ici?
Dr. Simon: Attends, tu vas voir. C'est plus très long.
Tous: Ouaaah!
Dr. Simon: Hahaha!
Iris: YEEEES!
Dr. Simon: Et voilà!
Iris: La faille s'est ré-ouverte, on voit l'extérieur!
Dr. Simon: Exactement. Ses chutes et son désarroi l'ont fait tomber ici. Et de nouvelles chutes,
et son désarroi ont créé une nouvelle faille. Et tout le monde sait qu'une faille dans une faille, c'est une sortie!
Thomas: Une sortie créée avec le seum d'Hitler? Oh les génies!
Iris: Allez, on sort!
LaBuse: Wahaaa!
Thomas: Eliott, tu vas nous manquer... J'ai connu des humains moins humains que toi...
Dr. Simon: Allez, on y va!
Dr. Simon: Allez Iris, on rentre à la maison
Iris: Euh, laisse-moi la machine 5 minutes, papa. J'vais déposer Thomas
Dr. Simon: Ok mais ne mets pas trop de temps. Cette époque me fout le cafard!
Thomas: On dirait que... C'est le moment de se quitter, LaBuse...
LaBuse: Au revoir mon garçon. Parfois, les rencontres t'apprennent plein de choses, et avec toi, rien du tout.
A part l'amitié. Et j'me suis beaucoup amusé.
Thomas: Ravi de t'avoir rencontré LaBuse.  Ne change rien. Sauf les viols. Et les assassinats.
Iris: Allez Thomas, on y va.
Thomas: Docteur Simon, LaBuse, je vous dis au revoiiiIIIIIIR
Mère de Thomas: Oh, Thomas! T'es revenu! Oh, bah je vois que t'as ramené ta petite copine! Comme quoi, le physique c'est pas important!
Thomas: Merci maman! Iris, on va dans ma chambre?
Iris: Allez...
Mère de Thomas: Oh non non non non non! Attends mon fils, attends! Ta chambre elle est...
Comment dire...
Thomas: Maman?! Mais qu'est ce que t'as fait de ma chambre?!
Mère de Thomas: Thomas, tu n'ouvres pas les tiroirs!
Thomas: C'est quoi ces fouets, cette cage et ce... truc?
Mère de Thomas: J't'avais prévenu!
Thomas: J'suis parti combien de temps?
Eliott: 2 jours!
Thomas et Iris: Eliott?! T'es pas mort?
Eliott: Si, après j'ai rechargé une sauvegarde dans une autre cafetière et je suis venu vous rejoindre
Iris: Mais on croyait que t'étais mort pour toujours!
Eliott: Bah non, je vous ai même dit... "On se revoit de l'autre côté"
Thomas: mais tout le monde croyait que ça voulait dire "On se revoit au Paradis"! Non? Y'a que moi?
Eliott: Non, c'était de l'autre côté de la faille! C'est vrai que vous les humains, vous prenez beaucoup de risques
pour des gens qui n'ont pas de sauvegarde. En tout cas, je suis très heureux de voir que mon plan a marché!
Mais je crois que vous avez des choses à vous dire
Iris: Merci Eliott. Bon, Thomas, assieds-toi sur cette balançoire en... cuir
Thomas: AH! Ca pique!
Iris: Bah nan, pas celle avec des piquants! Voilà, écoute. Je sais qu'on a vécu des aventures folles, ça c'est clair,
et c'est vrai que ça nous a rapprochés...
Thomas: C'est bon je sais, c'est fini entre nous. D'ailleurs pour toi ça avait pas vraiment commencé,
je vois bien que j't'intéresse pas... Et j'te comprends, c'est c'que j'voulais dire à ton père. J'voulais lui dire que
si j'avais la chance d'avoir une personne comme toi dans ma vie, aucune machine, aucune invention n'écarterait mon regard d'elle
Iris: C'est gentil...
Thomas: C'est bizarre, j'nous imaginais vivre ensemble, avoir des enfants, un chien...
Iris: Mais... Ca n'arrivera pas. Tu sais, je
Lapin: Iris, Thomas!!!
Thomas: Ouaouh, un petit lapin qui parle! Il est trop mignon!
Iris: Bah, t'es qui toi?
Lapin: Iris, Thomas, c'est à propos de votre fils, c'est urgent! J'ai besoin que vous me suiviez  travers le temps
L'avenir de la planète en dépend!
Thomas: On a eu un enfant?!
Iris: Hein, quoi?!
Eliott: C'est parti
Lapin: Suivez-moi!
Narrateur: Et dans un instant, la suite de l'aventure de
Non, j'déconne. C'est la fin de la saison.
C'est ce qu'on appelle un Cliffhanger. Qui est ce lapin? Que s'est-il passé entre Iris et Thomas dans le futur?
Qu'est-ce qui menace la planète? Autant de questions auxquelles les scénaristes n'ont aucune réponse!
Et ils sont pas dans la merde. Pour une fois, je sais pas tout... J'ai hâte de vous retrouver pour la suite de l'Epopée Temporelle
Cyprien: Merci d'avoir écouté le dernier épisode de la première saison de l'Epopée Temporelle
Merci beaucoup et n'hésite pas à t'abonner et à mettre un pouce en l'air
Et moi je te dis à très vite pour de nouvelles vidéos et pour la prochaine saison
A travers les époques, les dangers
Une grande aventure les appelle
C'est, c'est, c'est l'Epopée Temporelle